when a guy like smiles at you and kind
of laughs and then like looks down like
he's like and he looks back up at you
for like big hands and big heads and
lots of hair I don't know what this is
about a great nose like a Greek god a
little like three days haven't shaved
look I'm all about some man hand ears
that stick out a little bit tone cabs I
think are pretty awesome calves that
guys got mad calf messy hair with a lot
of volume I'm really attracted to a bald
head tighter jeans but not like tight
where it's like you can see balls like
shirts that fit in general boys you
gotta just wear stuff that fits think
they're called waffle shirt thermo
Henley shirt underneath and they matter
they're incredibly sexy gangster hood
look but with the preppy and the nerdy
urban geek a tasteful amount of tattoos
and cowboy hat someone who was really
analytical and is able to carry on deep
conversations is probably one of the
sexiest things about a man the one thing
that will get me are guys that have swag
somebody thinks outside of themselves
swag is so important that are really
attractive when you see them with kids
or with a baby you just you see me like
always the man of the baby
marry me already who knows how to
communicate passionate about something
someone that I can laugh with he thinks
that I'm funny or smart those are
killers playful arguing that stuff Oh
perhaps your face when you kisses you
see the hands on the face or take her by
the back of the neck and then hand on
the face always do that because it's so
amazingly hot if his bathroom is
immaculate because you're like oh I can
poop here yeah so I can date you right
if I cook here and then we can have
setting room get get your freak on and
get your poop on we're all in one place
yeah
[Music]